last time we talked about um that whole
thing with
um you know the nexium yeah
the whole she's going on trial i think
alison
she is and i remember we talked about
that but we i hadn't really seen
next thing the the show what was it
called
the vowel right i hadn't seen it
were you blown away when you watched it
yeah i was how did you feel after
watching that
sad sad yeah sad for her
but also um hurt
that she came for me too so were you
close to doing it you think
i wasn't not i mean she invited me it
was that weekend i just couldn't afford
to do you think you could have
gone through because when you watched
the first episode i i've said this
before in a podcast i was like
i'm in i'm [ __ ] in these people are
motivational they're here to help you
they're supportive they
invite you in and if you're at all
vulnerable
you could easily slip inside this this
world
and think this is going to help me be
the best
i can be and unfortunately and i think
that's why everybody got into it
and then all this [ __ ] happens and it
makes you just question everything you
also wonder if while you're in it
you would read how quickly you would
realize
what it was yeah that's scary like it it
took
them a while um yeah it
uh and i wasn't close with allison so i
i struggled with my feelings about it
because i had always wanted to get to
know her when we were shooting
yeah and then the one time she did reach
out to me years after smallville was for
that so it was kind of a weird
what year was that for her god i just
moved to la because she she found out i
just moved so it's 2010
11 yeah i don't know and was it a big
sell
was it like a no it was a very soft cell
it like in terms of oh she says you know
you come and join us
and we'll do we have books and it's a
women's group and
it's this much money and you thought
about it
i thought about it i also thought it
sounded odd i was like there's something
weird
here because she's never talked to me
before you know
she really never talked to you on the
set she she would in passing like we
never really had scenes together
she was pleasant to you but not overtly
yeah she didn't need to be we never
worked together i never spent time with
her which is why it was odd when she
reached out how did you feel about that
i think it was i was just in denial with
tom we were just like
i really didn't pay attention to it for
a while until it was in everyone's face
around the news i mean you knew her well
so well i didn't know her
well i was on set with her we did scenes
together i directed her
um she was always sweet she was always
always knew her lines always gave
a hundred percent uh it was a joy to
work with
um you never think in a million years
that that would happen and you could you
go back though
you look back and you're like huh like
you saw that
she needed attention but i'm like okay i
need attention you need attention we all
need attention
but i don't know what she was i didn't
know her well enough because
it was obvious that she needed something
she needed something else and i don't
think it was what it ended up being
i think she just thought i need some i
want to be loved
i want to be in a group that i feel
comfortable she didn't go in i want to
be the best i can be
she didn't go in knowing of course not
so you can't fault her for that i think
she just got lost it's kind of like a
breakup in that
you think you know someone and then you
find out they cheated and then you go
back moment by moment trying to figure
out
where things were starting to unravel so
for her when you say you were going back
thinking about her on set over the years
it's it's that
it's the same thing yeah
you